>>> THIS IS THE THICK OF IT.
WE ARE IN THE MIDDLE OF IT RIGHT
NOW.
YOU CAN HEAR THAT ROAR.
I MEAN, IT IS THE SOUND OF A
CATEGORY 3ISH STORM.
AND THIS IS THE POWER.
>> WHAT A PERFECT DESCRIPTION
THERE, THE ROAR OF A HURRICANE.
THE ENTIRE FEEL OF IT, EVEN
BEFORE THE WIND STARTS TO BLOW
AND THE RAIN STARTS TO COME
DOWN, IS SIMPLY OTHER WORLDLY
AND NOT IN A GOOD WAY.
AT THE TOP OF THE PROGRAM, WE
SHOWED YOU SOME REMARKABLE VIDEO
OF A WOMAN ON ANNA MARIE ISLAND
SWIMMING THROUGH FLOOD WATERS.
HER NAME IS ALEXIS DE LEONE, AND
HE JOINS US NOW.
THANK YOU, ALEXIS, SO MUCH FOR
JOINING US.
IT'S WONDERFUL THAT WE ARE
LOOKING AT YOU RIGHT NOW.
CAN YOU WALK US THROUGH WHAT YOU
EXPERIENCED -- OR MAYBE I SHOULD
SAY SWIM US THROUGH WHAT YOU
EXPERIENCED AS THE STORM BEGAN
TO PICK UP?
>> YEAH.
THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
I'M SUPER GLAD TO BE HERE.
IT WAS SCARY TO SAY THE LEAST.
YOU KNOW, WE DECIDED TO STAY OUT
THERE AND NOT LEAVE THE ISLAND.
SO, THAT WAS A PRETTY SCARY
DECISION IN THE FIRST PLACE, BUT
WE KIND OF KNEW THIS STORM
WASN'T GOING TO BE AS MUCH WIND
AND RAIN AS WE'RE TYPICALLY USED
TO WITH STORMS.
SO, WE JUST KNEW THAT STORM
SURGE WAS GOING TO BE COMING IN.
MIXED WITH THAT HIGH TIDE, THAT
WAS THE SCARIEST PART.
YOU KNOW, ONCE WE STARTED SEEING
THE TIDE COME UP, WE WAITED
UNTIL -- IT WAS STARTING TO GO
BACK DOWN BEFORE WE STARTED
VENTURING OUT AND WE REALIZED IT
WASN'T COMING UP INTO OUR HOUSE.
WE HAD SOME NEIGHBORS WHO CAME
UP NEXT TO THE TRAILER PARK.
THEY ARE FLOODED THROUGH THERE.
SO, WE DECIDED TO VENTURE OUT.
THAT'S WHERE YOU SAW THAT CLIP
THERE, JUST DOWN THE STREET FROM
US.
>> I'M LOOKING AT THIS VIDEO NOW
FOR THE FIRST TIME.
THAT'S AN AWFUL LOT OF WATER.
THAT IS AN AWFUL LOT OF WATER.
YOU SAID YOU DECIDED TO STAY
BECAUSE YOU HEARD THAT THE WINDS
AND THE RAINS WEREN'T GOING TO
BE SERIOUS.
BUT YOU KNEW THERE WAS GOING TO
BE STORM SURGE.
WHEN THAT STORM SURGE WAS COMING
IN, DID YOU FEEL LIKE YOU'D MADE
A QUESTIONABLE DECISION?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, AFTER SEEING
HURRICANE IAN LAST YEAR, I THINK
IT KIND OF GIVES EVERY FLORIDIAN
THAT LITTLE SCARED MOMENT IN THE
BACK OF YOUR HEAD, YOU KNOW?
WE ACT ALL TOUGH AND WE'RE ALL
READY FOR THE STORMS AND EXCITED
AND WHATEVER, BUT YOU NEVER KNOW
WHAT CAN REALLY HIT YOU IN THAT
TIME.
I THINK ONCE ME AND MY SISTER,
WE SAW IT COMING UP.
IT GOT A LITTLE SCARY, ONCE WE
STARTED REALIZING HOW HIGH IT
WAS ACTUALLY COMING UP.
GOLF CARTS, CARS WERE FLOODED,
THE TRAILER HOMES.
IT WAS UP TO OUR KNEES, OUR
WASTE.
IT GOT PRETTY HIGH.
>> FILMED SWIMMING, WHICH IS
AMAZING TO SEE.
NORMALLY WHEN YOU SEE SOMEONE IN
A SITUATION WHERE THEY HAVE TO
SWIM THROUGH STORM SURGE,
THERE'S A LOT OF TIMES THAT
WON'T END WELL.
BUT EXPLAIN HOW IT GOT TO THAT
POINT WHERE YOU HAD TO SWIM
THROUGH IT.
>> SO, YEAH, SWIMMING.
WHEN WE GOT DOWN TO THAT PART OF
THE STREET, WE HAD ORIGINALLY
WALKED THROUGH THERE.
AND THAT WATER IS ACTUALLY
PROBABLY ABOUT WAIST HIGH THERE.
AND WE WERE WEARING, YOU KNOW,
OUR SHOES, AND THEY WERE JUST
GETTING PELTED THROUGH THE
BOTTOM WITH DEBRIS AND SHELLS
AND BARNACLES, I MEAN, ANYTHING
THAT YOU COULD BE WALKING OVER
IN THAT TIME.
SO, WE FELT IN THAT MOMENT, IN
THAT SPECIFIC SPOT IN THE
STREET, IT WAS PROBABLY BEST
JUST TO SWIM SO WE WERE ABOVE
THE GROUND.
AND THEN SHORTLY THEREAFTER, WE
WERE LUCKILY ABLE TO WALK OUT.
BUT IT WAS STILL COVERING UP
HALF OUR BODIES WALKING THROUGH
THE STREETS.
>> WHAT MADE YOU DECIDE TO FILM
IT, TO SHOOT THE VIDEO AND THEN
POST IT ON TIKTOK?
>> I MEAN, I TIKTOK EVERYTHING
ELSE IN MY LIFE.
I'M A -- SO I DO THAT, AND YOU
KNOW, RECORD THE REST OF MY
LIFE.
LAST YEAR DURING HURRICANE IAN,
I ACTUALLY DID THE SAME THING.
AND I'VE HAD HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE
IN MY TOWN AND PEOPLE WHO
VACATION HERE -- IT'S SUCH A BIG
AREA THAT EVERYONE KNOWS -- THEY
REALLY THANKED ME FOR AND WERE
REALLY GRATEFUL THEY COULD SEE
THE DAMAGE THAT WAS DONE AND HOW
WELL WE DID OR DIDN'T DO IN THAT
TIME.
REALLY I WAS THINKING ABOUT A
LOT OF THOSE PEOPLE AND SHOWING
THEM WHAT WAS GOING ON AND
EASING THEIR MINDS A LITTLE.
>> AND ARE PEOPLE REACHING OUT?
ARE YOUR FRIENDS AND NEIGHBORS
WHO LEFT REACHING OUT TO YOU AND
SAYING, HEY, HOW IS MY HOME?
>> OH, YEAH.
OH, YEAH.
I MEAN, I HAVE HUNDREDS AND
HUNDREDS -- PROBABLY THOUSANDS,
OVER 1,000 DMs ON TIKTOK AND
INSTAGRAM.
COMMENTS, SEVERAL HUNDRED
COMMENTS, OF PEOPLE GIVING ME
THEIR EXACT ADDRESS, THEIR
STREET.
HEY, CAN YOU GO BY HERE.
THE ISLAND WAS SHUT DOWN UNTIL
ABOUT 5:00 P.M. TODAY.
SO, NO ONE COULD GET ON.
NO ONE KNEW WHAT IT WAS LIKE.
I WAS ONE OF THE VERY FEW PEOPLE
STILL OUT THERE.
SO, I WAS JUST GOING UP AND DOWN
EACH BLOCK VIDEOING AS MUCH AS I
COULD AND JUST POSTING IT SO
PEOPLE COULD MAYBE SEE THEIR
HOUSE AND SEE THAT IT WAS OKAY
THROUGHOUT THE STORM.
>> ALEXIS, WE APPRECIATE YOU
BEING WITH US.
WE APPRECIATE YOU SHARING YOUR
EXPERIENCE WITH US.
AGAIN, I SHOULD NOTE THAT THIS
IS THE TYPE OF THING OFFICIALS
WARN PEOPLE AGAINST DOING.
THEY SAY THIS IS NOT A WISE
THING TO DO.
NEVERTHELESS, WE ARE GLAD YOU
MADE IT THROUGH.
WE'RE GLAD YOU CAN SMILE TONIGHT
ABOUT THE EXPERIENCE.
>>> TO THE NORTH OF ANNA MARIE
ISLAND, HERNANDO COUNTY ALSO
SUFFERED SERIOUS DAMAGE.
JOINING US NOW IS SHERIFF AL
NEEN HICE.
SHERIFF, I UNDERSTAND THERE WERE
SEVERAL RESCUES DONE THIS
MORNING IN YOUR COUNTY.
HOW MANY AND ARE THERE STILL
PEOPLE OUT THERE WHO NEED TO BE
RESCUED?
>> FORTUNATELY, THERE WERE ONLY
ONE OR TWO.
ONE OF THEM WAS A LITTLE BIT
MORE DRAMATIC THAN SOME OF THE
OTHER ONES.
WE HAD A LADY AND HER YOUNG SON
THAT WERE IN THEIR VEHICLE ON A
BRIDGE IN PINE ISLAND, WHICH IS
KIND OF IN THE NORTHWEST PART OF
OUR COUNTY.
IT'S A BEAUTIFUL ISLAND.
AND THEY DECIDED THEY WANTED TO
LEAVE THE ISLAND RIGHT AT THE
PEAK OF THE STORM SURGE.
AND THEY WERE STUCK ON A BRIDGE
OUT THERE.
AND FOR A COUPLE OF HOURS, WE
WERE TRYING TO GET THEM OFF.
AND FORTUNATELY, WORKING WITH
FIRE RESCUE AND ONE OF THE
DIVISION CHIEFS OF FIRE RESCUE,
MARK SAUL, HE WAS MANNING THE
AIRBOAT THERE.
AND HE WAS ABLE TO GET TO THEM
AND GET THEM BACK TO SHORE
SAFELY.
THEY WERE CHECKED OUT VERY
BRIEFLY BY FIRE RESCUE AND WERE
ABLE TO BE REUNITED WITH FAMILY.
TO SAY IT WAS -- I JUST HAPPENED
TO BE THERE AT THE TIME MYSELF
WITH ONE OF OUR COUNTY
COMMISSIONERS.
IT WAS HEARTWARMING TO SAY THE
LEAST, BECAUSE IT COULD HAVE
TURNED OUT VERY BADLY.
>> LUCKY FOR THEM THAT YOU WERE
THERE AND ABLE TO GET TO THEM.
HAS THERE BEEN ANY SIGNIFICANT
DAMAGE TO HOMES AND OTHER
STRUCTURES?
>> YEAH.
WE HAVE -- I THINK THAT FIRE --
ACTUALLY WE HAD A SIMILAR
SITUATION TO WHAT YOU'RE SEEING
ON THE SCREEN NOW IN HERNANDO
BEACH.
WE DID HAVE A HOUSE FIRE, AT
LEAST ONE OR TWO.
I THINK THERE WAS ONE IN -- AS
WELL RIGHT AT THE HEIGHT OF THE
STORM SURGE.
AND UNFORTUNATELY, FIRE AND
RESCUE COULDN'T GET TO THEM
RIGHT AWAY.
SO, IT TOOK SOME TIME, AND I
THINK THERE WAS SOME SIGNIFICANT
DANG THERE.
WE ALSO HAVE SEVERAL DOZEN
HOUSES WITH WATER IN THEM.
WE'RE STILL ASSESSING THEM.
I AM VERY HAPPY TO REPORT THAT
AS OF RIGHT NOW, WE DON'T KNOW
OF ANY INJURIES, MUCH LESS ANY
FATALITIES THAT OCCURRED BECAUSE
THE VAST MAJORITY OF PEOPLE
HEEDED THE WARNING AND
UNDERSTOOD IT WAS MUCH BETTER TO
BE ON DRY LAND WISHING THEY WERE
OUT ON THE BEACH THAN TO BE OUT
ON THE BEACH WISHING THEY HAD
GONE TO DRY LAND.
SO, FORTUNATELY, THE RESIDENTS
HERE HAVE BEEN THROUGH THIS A
FEW TIMES AND HEEDED OUR
WARNINGS.
AND THE ONES THAT DID STAY ON
THE BEACH, WE WERE FORTUNATE
THAT THE STORM SURGE OCCURRED
DURING LOW TIDE.
SO, IT WASN'T NEAR AS BAD IN
HERNANDO COUNTY AS IT COULD HAVE
BEEN HAD THE STORM BEEN SIX
HOURS FASTER OR SIX HOURS
SLOWER.
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN MUCH, MUCH
WORSE FOR US.
>> THAT IS WONDERFUL NEWS AND I
HOPE IT STICKS, NO INJURIES IN
YOUR COUNTY.
WHAT DO YOU THINK THE NEXT 24
HOURS LOOK LIKE FOR YOU?
>> WELL, THE NEXT 24 HOURS IS
OBVIOUSLY TRYING TO MAKE THOSE
PEOPLE THAT HAVE SUSTAINED SOME
DAMAGE, PARTICULARLY WATER
DAMAGE IN THEIR HOUSE, TRYING TO
GIVE THEM PEACE OF MIND THAT THE
SHERIFF'S OFFICE IS GOING TO BE
OUT THERE KEEPING THEIR HOMES
SAFE, WHETHER THEY'RE IN THEIR
HOMES, WHETHER THEY'RE NOT ABLE
TO STAY IN THEIR HOMES.
AND WE'RE GOING TO HAVE PEOPLE
OUT ON THE WATER AND OF COURSE
ON THE LAND.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A LOT OF
DEPUTIES IN THE AREA MAKING SURE
THAT SOME OF THOSE PEOPLE THAT
WOULD STOOP TO TAKING ADVANTAGE
OF THIS SITUATION IN A CRIMINAL
WAY, WE'RE GOING TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN.
AND IF WE DO CATCH ANYBODY, THEY
CAN REST ASSURED THEY'RE GOING
TO BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR THAT.
>> ALL RIGHT.
HERNANDO COUNTY SHERIFF, THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING WITH US.
WISHING YOU THE BEST OF LUCK IN
THE COMING DAYS.